[Music]
so last week I got a chance to play some
Dragon Age Inquisition EA had a had a
little event here in the city and so it
was me and some other press members we
went in and it was basically just
unfettered time with the game starting
at the beginning and leading to as far
as we got in the in the three and a half
or four hours that we spent with it I
can't talk about everything due to
spoilers but I can certainly give you
some impressions of what I am allowed to
talk about and that starts with the
character creation because I'm was
pretty impressed with the character
creation unexpectedly so there are a lot
of ways of establishing a character you
get you get four races to choose from
human Alf canari and dwarf this is the
first time the Qunari has been playable
but I I ended up going with an elf and
I'm really happy that I did because I
got a chance to really play around to
character customization options in it
they're much more in depth than I ever
expected them to be so to give you an
example I mean you're used to being able
to set eye color and you know even in
certain games like the spacing of the
eyes and the eyebrows and all that kind
of stuff like how long the nose is how
big the joy is and it's got all that
kind of stuff but it goes even further
than that it's to the point where you
don't get to choose just I color but you
can choose the inner cornea color versus
the outer coordinate color to make eyes
look even more like real-life eyes and
there are tons of like tattoo options
and makeup options and all sorts of
stuff like that and so what I ended up
doing is I created this elf that I was
trying to make look very lovely and as I
went on I actually used some of the
makeup options and tattoo options and I
I gave them like really really cool eyes
with some white eyeliner and things like
that the downside is that by the time I
got into the actual game a character
that looked good in the character
creation screen I ended up sticking out
a little bit
the main game my poor elf looked a
little too colorful around his
compatriots but that would that was okay
another thing that I really liked about
it is that you get two you get several
different voice options even for the
same gender so if you choose a if you
choose a male character you have two
different male voices and if you choose
a female character II of two different
female voices I just hope I can help
everything you've heard completely true
so the rest of the stuff that I can talk
about is the gameplay in the hinterlands
which is this it really is a grassy
forest II area I was playing on the ps4
but I did get a chance to play around a
little bit with the with the tactical
camera which is not only back but isn't
just for PC players but also for console
players and and I didn't spend tons of
time with it but I but one thing that I
really liked is is the the forward
button so in other words in the past
like if you're playing I Swindell or
baldur's gate you go or Dragon Age even
and you go into the tactical camera you
know when you play those games you pause
issue your things unpause until the time
comes to pause again and then you pause
and in this case instead of pausing and
unpausing you have a forward button that
you just hold down to progress time
forward and let go when you when you
need to let it go and it's effectively
the same thing but it's it's a much
smoother kind of experience as a result
of that and I really like that they've
embraced that idea the rest of the time
though I kind of did it from a
third-person more action RPG kind of
perspective and actually that ended up
being a lot more satisfying than I
expected to be I played as a mage you
know you have your your main basic
attack which which you perform just by
holding that you know by holding a
shoulder button and then you hit you
know you hit various buttons to pull off
the the other spells in it it felt
really good there's a nice lock on that
you can use to lock on to enemies at
which point the camera sort of zooms in
so you get a better view of what's going
on otherwise there there's still Auto
targeting and when you when you perform
your spells but it'll go to whatever
enemy to get the game thinks is the
appropriate one whereas you can so
choose enemies by a walking console
Batman felt it felt right it felt very
good the hinterlands is also a big place
no I did it with a full party you get
your own character that you yourself
create you get Varrick who returns from
Dragon Age 2 as far as I know he's the
only returning character that can also
be a party number so that's fun or I
should say the only returning party
member that can now be a party member
but the Sandra also joins you in these
early hours and if you don't remember
who Cassandra is she's the she's the
Inquisitor that's interrogating Varrick
at the very beginning of Dragon Age 2 so
you get Cassandra with you and then you
get another mage in the end of the
exploration felt really good moving
around the hinterlands as was was really
easy and quests are really easy to take
so you know you've got your story quests
and the game leads you really well from
place to place with story quests but as
you go out into the world and this is
not like corridors going through I mean
it is somewhat like that but I think you
can think of it set up sort of like
Kingdoms of Amalur was where it's not an
entirely open world but they're large
open spaces that are connected either by
corridors or or by loading screens
there's not only quests that you come
across either by coming across people
that have stuff to offer you or by you
know wandering into say a Shack and
there's a diary there and then that can
initiate a quest for you as well I was
playing on regular difficulty there
wasn't at first I really didn't run into
any trouble and for the most part I
didn't I could play as sort of a
third-person action game with my people
at my side only occasionally pausing and
asking them to do things like use
potions and whatnot one time I did
stumble upon a dragon quite accidentally
and I initiated battle that involved not
just the large dragon flying overhead
and bombarding us but also little light
little live urns on the ground and I had
my ass handed to me pretty pretty easily
it would have been a good place to
actually start to micromanage that
battle but I had limited time so instead
of trying to bash against that
particular dragon I chose to go off and
do something else and come back later
you know what I played it seems like
they've got something that's a little
bit there for everybody depending on
what you like from RPGs I mean you know
it's it's easy to say hey this isn't as
much like Dragon Age Origins as I would
like but it does sort of have that and
it gives you an opportunity to play that
way if you want to I really like that
about it but also if you go into
something feeling like you want a little
bit more of an action RPG it feels
really good to play from just a typical
third-person perspective you also get to
level up your your skills and your
spell's and I didn't investigate that
tree too much I did level up my
characters as I went but the good news
is of course that you've still got
Varrick using Bianca beau and you will
get to upgrade that in certain ways but
the the trees looked a lot like they did
in Dragon Age 2 where in some cases you
get a chance to either you know when you
spell it you spend the skill point you
can spend it on something new or you can
spend it perhaps on an enhancement of
the one that you already have one
interesting thing about health potions
is that you start with eight total
potions across the party that you can
use and whenever you go back to camp
you replenish that they're not really
inventory items as it were I sort of
think of it more as the way Dark Souls
handles its Estus flasks which is like
you know this is the potions that you
get you get to refill the help anytime
you go back to a base camp so at the
stage it's clear to when you're when
you're making decisions and dialogue I
haven't done anything that's too wild
and crazy' just yet no great decision
when I was playing in the first three
hours but obviously ways to sort of
build up my character before that you
know do I want to be an [ __ ]
or you know do I want to be you know
nice about stuff and of course you get
to go back and forth between those if
you so desire and the game does tell you
how it affects your relationships with
other characters when you do that it
will it's sort of sort of Walking Dead
style in the sense that you know hey
your relationship has been improved
somewhat with this person or so-and-so
didn't like what you had to say so it's
a little bit more upfront then then
previous games were about how you're
affecting your relationships with other
people when you make those decisions
even though I only had like three and a
half hours four hours with the game or
so there's there's a lot more to talk
about and I could keep going on and on
but I think I'd probably get boring at
that point but suffice it to say I'm
actually really looking forward to
getting my hands on the full game at
this stage I don't know exactly what to
expect yet I mean I feel like Bioware is
in a position where they made people a
little bit unhappy with Dragon Age 2 not
being in the in the same ballpark as
Dragon Age 1 when it came to quality and
I feel like a lot of people got burn out
on that Mass Effect 3 ending so the
question is going to be is this is this
the the return to what people want from
Bioware and something tells me that you
know they're always going to be
naysayers there'll always be people that
that they complain about stuff but
something tells me that this this is a
good step towards getting people you
know back you know back on their side I
think that what I play the Dragon Age
Inquisition was was really good and
hopefully cool game ends up being just
as good as what I hope it would be
[Music]
[Music]